but she also had a lot of people who
like wanted to speak with you guys I'm
so late I'm sorry but that was
completely it was that the crazy The
Terminator was a London mommy's here
thank you guys thank you I would
actually argue that this was a little
bit crazier all right guys Thank You
Darla it felt different Oh
exclusive DJ peds
I agree mom the time stamps make it seem
much more serious dheere dheere dheere
dheere act doesn't put him in enough
yeah
I said he's sitting and filming right
now some making fun of him I always tell
I always tell them the time stamps
matter because it makes people
understand how ridiculous it really is
oh crap I forgot about a call I had mom
sorry I love you I gotta grab this let
me fight hey guys sorry about that got
caught up with my mom
and there's
Oh dragging such a nice day though like
if it was like if it was raining right
now I would be like you know what I'm
finished you can't trust them you got to
go to something else
which are person end discounted prices
for the next two hours you know
something like that yes I'm the diver
oh good one morning but then you get es
you're gonna get swept by the mess and
then that's gonna be it
there's meaning about us going through
our list building the sub list yeah do
we know nothing about music at all then
nosey unless we betting Dino Bieber on
like I won't know any of the work you'll
probably get him tonight
Oh God what if we can't pull in our SP
any you know what happened what about
out but it touch me out there clear
alive okay let's go anyway
Bobby hey Roxy hey guys are you gonna
see it floor one
as I said
hello who waited a freaking make out a
nice day huh you again how are you good
to see over you I thought well yeah well
yeah for sure how you been pretty good
pretty good
very cool awesome Evan say thank you we
got you how are you I'm good I'm good my
man I love listening Thank You doll wow
you're awesome thank you so much all
right
you'll drop the Pella frozen do you
rocks here I got to go on stage and a
half an hour
oh yes according to kind of thank you
man
oh thank you man hey man how are you I
think yeah no worries
how are you good master teach I've been
super cell for a very long time so nice
can I see you you're welcome
great how are you thank you you got it
all your books you've been watching for
years some are awesome back huh hey man
how are you is snapchat Thank You Man
what your name is and as you know I need
to come out of here I just want to be
behind this gateway thank you thank you
very much thank you thank you much thank
you hi my cell we met right now are you
sure yes how are you I love you and
clear oh my god thank you senior person
to me nice to meet you yeah sure Tracy
yeah TREC one thought up seem to be
singularly focused on exit thank you
thank you show everyone your motivation
well thank you man I must say mr. face
asleep anything you show me man I think
I'll feel about a penny and I got a pen
Thank You Taylor thank you sir
Malcolm how are you Scott away jersey
cloud it what a Jersey how are you good
good manager attitude constant about
four five months - Thank You Man Oh your
stuff got me fired up thank you for a
special dancer local fitness instructor
for you getting ready to come to figure
out my brand yeah no no take it with the
ground running just just put out chef
don't don't don't overthink it just
start putting out Fitness dancing
there's no perfect system there's no
perfect contact get it out and start and
see what people react to all your
friends the random people that say it so
I'm starting to get up get my target
audience down oh don't even think about
that like your target your target
audiences everybody like too many people
[ __ ] themselves to start like anytime
somebody comes to me and says I'm about
to get my content out this is why I jump
in them like doing right now like golf
yeah man that's a big picture yeah of
course oh yes Dmitri Dmitri are you
possible hello thanks for the
inspiration yeah man good luck - sure
yeah real pleasure thank you sure yeah
are you gonna think - what's up Gary my
name is Dennis just want to say you
inspire me
everything you do everything dailyvee
with askgaryvee show everything you've
done screaming offense Mike sorry yeah
yeah thank you do everything that you do
all that you are thinking it was for
that reason
okay would I lie it makes me so happy
picture Rob Lee original abusers a shot
fly awesome man I'm gonna say anything
yeah of course you want to figure hand
thank you thank you thank you so much I
gotta get ready I'm getting moved up I'm
sorry yeah get yourself ease set up if
you want to sneak it in because I got to
run your search for council man keep
I'll ask you one thing
yes what are you first thing you do when
you make up developer take a [ __ ] take
[ __ ] okay good that's like tear down man
yes I shouldn't be a celebrity now these
are the pressure because you know I'm
sorry no longer the wine guy there -
pretty bad right your brand that's some
level I knew was gonna happen you know
sometimes you just know I'm on wave
right all it does is exposes who you are
it doesn't mean right yeah so I'm like
it doesn't change you like I sorry I'll
see you guys up there but my biggest
thing was I've been at this hustle man
for like you but I wasn't as successful
as you with 90 combination it happened
10 years in the me you know what's crazy
actually you can bring us up I don't run
Facebook pages started seven years ago
from seven years ago to three weeks ago
my facebook fanpage number was 500,000
in the last three weeks it's now at
seven hundred twenty thousand high 50
percent growth in three years after
doing everything right by everybody's
eyes for eight years yeah like it's just
a grind it's just a grind non-stop like
you never know when it's gonna be the
event like this could have been rained
out people pup pulled out like you know
sometimes the Sun just decides to shine
on you you know what I mean seriously
but I'll tell you someone's gonna brain
[ __ ] you on the flip side and I've been
here like 12 times already you feel like
this is it yeah this is my coming-out
party and then it's next Thursday and
you're like wait a minute why might wise
not everybody stopping taking something
sunny like that
likewise it why am I not on Conan like
it's unbelievable that like you know
what I mean like right now that's what
if I'm you that's what I'm feeling
I totally this is it I know and then
tonight a me like wait what everybody go
no tonight's even better to recap it
right yeah that's Luke you're like hmm
and you know so but this is an
incredible ungodly start and I'm so
happy that it's in New Jersey you could
not imagine super great day big big
coming-out party for Jersey huge event
how many people we got 7500 registers
and these and we think we might at
10,000 another day amazing we were very
specific some people might think that
we've chose you because you have a huge
following but we chose you because you
come from here and you represent this
awesome and have a huge swallowing end
everything
got man get it dude hi how are you good
to see you be Gary manager okay
let's clap it up for this [ __ ] day
how nice is this that's the real star of
the show
forget the panel's the [ __ ] Sun came
out start figuring out how to make money
because if you're sitting right now and
you burn and your life depends on
raising your next round or your first
round you are extremely vulnerable and I
highly recommend and I don't care how
bright the sun is shining
you better get real [ __ ] practical
right now cuz shits coming down what we
people here do today the hell you have
nothing and that makes me happier than
coming up with something [ __ ] ourselves
that you believe in
oh lordy that'll make you feel good do
something nice for somebody else that
brings them value without having
expectations with something in return
which is something most of you can't do
thank you guys my pleasure thank you
thank you buddy hope you like this make
some noise for Gary Thank You Man good
job yeah thank you let's go let's go a
little recap halfway through the day
what just happened and I think you
should mash it off do you rock cuz that
was insanity a lot of crazy stuff much
loves everybody in Jersey [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] are we gonna do this can we go in
this good guys I'm so late I'm sorry but
thank you guys thank you all right guys
thank you darling Thank You Rosa
yes thank you guys thank you bye bye
guys thank you thank you crazy
to address supper second how you been
man I ran into some friends of yours
gotta get over there man good to see
that stay well
propeller you did a great job super
crazy Jersey love this man came through
had a great time
that's the hustle right there yes sir
that's the hustle right there that's the
real hustle do you rock this is what I'm
talking this is what I'm talking about
not that this is the real hustle this is
the real hustle
good luck how are you darling good
hustle I love it two things one give the
building inner circle for five people
that wouldn't leave you for anything in
the world right but that is the whole
game if you understand yeah and I'm
thrilled if I need to know you a little
more but after that and I can already
feel the vibe I'm thrilled to give you
connections all right bye-bye
thank you we're on three words give me
inspiration for any damn going down
three words three words you're gonna die
yeah that's inspiration do something
about it I love you too take care ready
I'm skidding weird you know it's
interesting when you actually have the
right strategy and you put in the work
behind it the results calm
and we started getting serious about
YouTube and we got and then I started
getting symphony even as recently as
December started getting me something
serious about snapchat and we got
serious about Instagram your change ago
and I'm sure you're gonna edit this with
timestamps don't let my mom down
I agree mom the timestamps make it seem
much more serious lots of time Stan I
really honestly think comments everybody
I think a lot more time stamps will help
I know it probably screws up your
beautiful movie skills but this is a
daily be I want time stamps um for mom
for mom yeah for my mom not for me um
you know it's just interesting I mean
what we just saw
stuffs interesting that wasn't happening
a year ago things have clearly changed
and it's because I've been delivering
the same message but delivering it in
the right mediums on the right platforms
with the right context with the right
consistency and it just it's meaningful
and it's having that right strategy
mobile first world producing a lot more
video because I'm a great video and
consistency consistency chopping it up
subtitles first five seconds Facebook
has exploded going from 500 to 700
20,000 fans in the home a month hitting
new demos
I'd like the sag predicted the virality
of that college video Iraq
I hedged I think he did it to be honest
I think I did everything's gone to a
completely different place and and
that's what happens for a lot of people
that do things right and and for a lot
of you actually that are watching that
I've been jamming with for a long time
some of you out there with the 50,000
100,000 following counts you know
who've been grinding along with me you
know you know and there's and I'm really
talking about demo which is like for all
you social media peeps who you know I
was if we're talking branding I was here
and you were here I think that same kind
of if you really look at my last 18
months that consistency that contextual
of content that investment in people I
think it worked for a lot of you then
there's a there's a real moment to this
transition of like consumption the TVs
now with the Apple TVs in the Netflix's
and mortification TVs seen you on the
big screen always being with you and
then that always consistent thing that I
never ever wavered from that engagement
overlaying that content
it's real stuffs happening stuff is
happening
yeah
and then I'll and then Allah and then
I'll once you guys have everything you
need will schedule around you uh like I
don't know here's one that I can get
tell you that I can probably get just
I'm only thinking top ten for not what
are to be to be the ten people we
eventually get I'm making the assumption
that we need to drill this first you
know hey hi little win oh damn it I
really wish that work boys
sir just talking about that he welcomes
it than anyone ever man yeah she really
Mary that's probably the worst call
bouncer in the met slack channel
yesterday I use like Harvey's gonna
throw into a hitter no I take it into
the seventh
Harvey throw no no no yes mom he got
into wrong prediction he got destroyed
guys wrong what's the matter Linux I on
at like I think last season everyone was
like no matter what she's looking out a
personal layoffs you gotta keep pushing
and his doctor was like you were done
pitching for the year and it threw 50
more innings and now we're dealing with
ramifications of all major now make it
worse I'm about to become friends with
I'm about to be called keep you updated
with it that's firm firm
but the others I'm like boys without the
other than somebody's Jacob degrom
that's okay at the end of what life is
whatever we're doing elevator ride how
about it
honest that's what I thought you bet be
within a second yo hey Viji hair first
of all why I dream we should do more
public transportation but you also had a
lot of people who might wanted to speak
with you that was completely it was that
the crazy system Athena was a London
mommy's here mm-hmm I would actually
argue that this was a little bit crazy
it felt uncommon we were no weird like
car driving away like here the book I
also do security guards like her yeah
yeah yes like they just were like wanted
don't like yeah dancers yes yes a once
outside my apartment all day yeah yeah
yeah yeah get out of here it can be
really a Charlotte Fishbach how are you
nice to meet you I love the hello how
are you okay how are you man - such a
pleasure - pleasure
well this is really exciting I've been
looking forward to it that's cute that's
good okay well thank you I'm flattered
big fan thank you so much thank you tell
me everything I want to get right like
you know I appreciate flying out and how
supporting my book and so I want to give
you as much value as I can please just
do me one favor if anything from this
meeting be know that I who I think you
all like very much and think scene it's
a very very very vulnerable model to a
brand more than people think it
absolutely it's a seductive model
because it scales fast and the monies
can come in but very quickly could
absolutely if you're not very careful
and smart and in acting if you are not
very smart about that you have to
understand one person in Spain can
really do damage somebody said something
interesting to me the other
he said Gary what impresses me about you
as you understand something my mentor
told me which is you can get there by
going 65 miles an hour just promise me
that all of you understand you can get
there by going 65 miles an hour
I'm thinking how do I bring you the most
value and we're gonna do a lot more
things I see there's a list I'll answer
them all I promise but that's important
I want to make sure you feel that for me
let me ask you a question I want to go
back to how you said franchising is not
the correct model do you think but
you're not saying turn off the cameras
unaligned your mission one video gets
post turn them off again
you start looking the other way one bad
video somebody goes in with a camera
goes into the clinic here's [ __ ]
this is what he's selling to us puts it
on Facebook goes viral hundred million
it's all over it's over quality control
gonna be key in this not key it's oxygen
a key not important not the first enlist
the only thing I gotta go Gary yes keep
it going right oh it's wrong
my heart
toady for five minutes before five then
jarett's the greatest we can come in
okay you got to leave in 35 minutes
Cody Cody I'm doing great man I'm gonna
meet you can see up here sit first I
love you
oh [ __ ] yeah good nice to meet your need
it away yeah man okay all right Phil
doing any working you know just keeping
the balls in the air but that is the
work sir man honestly that is the work
when people watch this they're like you
don't work I'm like are you a [ __ ]
idiot this is the work like keeping the
balls in the air is the work yeah the
problem is right it you're orchestrating
you're not playing the [ __ ] by Lin
bro Mason damn it good to see you too
Phil bye though yes so you have to put
it into the hinge all the over there
yeah right there okay and then okay wait
a little bit more okay you got to get in
there okay and then turn it like you
thrown up
nice nice and then wait wait I kick what
what is he say why I don't want to
extract you gotta do my teeth usually
see the whole show right hey hey good to
see you thank you so much that was
delicious
we got two we also have a bunch of
artists like we have like six articles
we need to find real time yeah thanks
brother see you later thank you
hello yep
how you doing good so tell what's up man
you know what I want you do yeah I want
you to make me five what we call BSU's
branded status updates that was my first
term of four Vayner you know what I'm
doing on Instagram yeah I want you to
make me five and send it to me boom
you're ahead miss your family
yeah little guys got something going on
so go see him I have to walk into my
little guys taught Shabbat Oh amazing
yeah I'll do in a couple hours so as
soon as I get out so it was interesting
kind of a couple hours did some family
time stuff with the kids
and now back out a little bit of a
preview of kind of my ambition for 2017
coming home and spending time with the
kids when I'm in New York and going back
out just looking at hack more time with
them and at the same time balance you
know my own wants and needs and concerns
about the fact that I don't know if I
can get the momentum back on to the day
but I think I can I was pretty excited
about like how energized I'm right now
and so I'll be interesting I'm really
looking forward to that chapter much
like the way I affected my health you
know I talk to myself a year 18 months
three months every system is different
but not system every every kind of
pillar that I want to make a change in
is different but I found it I found it I
found it and then I do it where there's
smoke there's fire
I'm creating smoke and now I'm talking
to you guys about it that's more smoke
really really intrigued and excited and
um felt pretty good it's a lot of a lot
of coffee's for you only a place that
you might have to sort carry your laptop
and edit
so back to the grind that was the
greatest feeding that men of business
have ever had the greatest a business
men
1001 p.m. Friday night don't think most
people are going to their next meeting
most people say they want it if their
actions don't reflect it cut off the
money part how are you brother
Danny doesn't see I remember I remember
I know damn it
yeah yeah you do disorder Scottie Pippen
he's the guy but he could tell them I'm
right this was fun that's not sure
that's not business he got training from
the Seattle didn't do [ __ ] he showed us
he's like thank God my kid over to their
ability you get the hug I think I
respect you're right about everything
too late like like what are you sure yes
it was what are you recognize it like it
wasn't mess probably Maxim 88 let's
flush by 12 facts guys please my Bose
best friend second best by magic I mean
come on he was sailors there was never a
time in 1988 would have every goes this
guy just said I Sam just got rolled out
with a [ __ ] Pabst Blue Ribbon 12-pack
just that doesn't give a [ __ ] that man
doesn't give a [ __ ]
that's real guy yeah people can tell the
difference everybody else
over the Daily Planet
all righty rocky you're a good night
good night
okay we love you elderly Fanny benefit
of being oh okay I came in you know good
day
BG yeah see